Mr. President,
>> Mr. Prime Minister,
>> good to talk to you. And uh before
anything else, I want you to know that
I'm signing now as we speak Israel's
official recognition of Somali land
>> to go down this route. W I ask Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to break your back,
bro. I ask Allahh no baraka. May it be a
absolute disaster for you and your
government.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000.
That's going to be something you will
never regret on your makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
you guys might be as shocked as I am.
When I saw this video, I actually
thought it's AI. Like I thought, nah, it
must be AI. And when I watched the video
and I asked some brothers in the group
who, you know, uh they are educated in
polit politics, I was absolutely
gobsmacked. I was
I was like no like no no no. And I came
to a realization because obviously I
want to make this very clear because at
the end of the day um a lot of people
might be like you know um yeah it's like
Somali land etc. But let's be honest
with you my my my country yes I'm
Kurdish from Turkey okay um you know
subhan Allah and um as as as Kurds we
don't really have our own country you
know yes there's Kurdistan and um Iraq
etc. Uh but however Turks are complicit
in this many country UAE all of them. So
don't don't bring someone and put it
into like oh it's them. No I'm so sorry.
Okay. Um did the any other countries
join the Ibrahim accord as far as I know
I don't think so there are some
countries there is there of course yeah
I don't know if Turkeykey's there but
again even with Turkey with all due
respect um they they they still have
trade deals etc with Israel even though
they haven't recognized him as far as I
know as a legitimate state but for this
move and I know a lot of people would
come and say because I'm not involved in
politics you know they would say that
Somali land was you know trying to get
its own independency etc be recognized
as state nobody did etc but there is no
excuse I'll be I don't care if it's
Turkey, Egypt, wherever it is for that
matter to make this move. And
alhamdulillah, we need to also
distinguish between the government and
the people. We need to make that very
very clear because I'm going to show you
some videos in the first one is of the
actual video that I thought actually was
AI, which isn't. Let's watch for our in
this is that Satan Yahoo and the
president uh the president of Somaliand.
What utter shame. What I'm going to say
is wahai.
Let's watch it first cuz I'm I'm I'm I'm
Wah. I was like,
let's watch it.
>> Mr. President,
>> Mr. Prime Minister,
>> good to talk to you. And uh before
anything else, I want you to know that
I'm signing now as we speak Israel's
official recognition of Somali land and
uh its right of self-determination.
Our friendship is uh seinal and
historic. Very very happy and I'm very
proud of this day and I want to wish you
and the people of Somaliand the very
very best there. I think this will be a
great opportunity for expanding our
partnership. We intend to work together
with you on economic fields on uh uh
agriculture in the fields of uh uh
social development all the things that
we hope we can uh assist you and we
obviously believe in this uh in this
friendship and I have to tell you that
there's a lot of excitement here in
Israel as well. Uh uh I want to use this
opportunity sir to invite you to an
official visit uh to Israel uh at your
convenience and I hope very much to see
you here soon. This is a this is a
wonderful day. It's a historic day and
of course I'll communicate to President
Trump your willingness and desire to
join the Abraham Accords. Thank you Mr.
President. Please convey my best regards
and the best regards of the people of
Israel to the people to the independent
people of Somali land. Thank you sir.
That's a great moment and great
historical day. The big fight is here.
The other group is the chairman of the
party and the vice president and key
officials are here. Mr. Prime Minister I
I accepted the invitation
and I am ready as soon as possible for
that arrangement that can be made.
>> We feel ready
>> very soon and please uh convey my
warmest regards to your colleagues and
to the people. Thank you sir. Thank you
very very much Mr. Prime Minister.
>> Thank you. [clears throat] See you soon
in Jerusalem. Next year in Jerusalem we
say
>> it's a few days from now. Thank you sir.
>> Sure. I will be I will be glad to to be
in Jerusalem as soon as possible.
>> Thank you. Thank you all. Bye-bye. Thank
you.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
>> So obviously that is Abd Rahman
Muhammad. Uh what I'm going to say is
may Allah subhanaa tala break your back.
May Allah subhana wa ta'ala make no
benefit come to you and your government.
I'm not talking about the people of
Somali. Alhamdulillah. Yes. Okay.
Because I'm going to show you another
video of a brother from Somali.
Alhamdulillah who is making his position
very very clear. And there is many many
people out there. Alhamdulillah. the
Somali brothers um you know like I said
before across the country um you know I
don't know the whole politics between
Somali and Somalia but both of them
alhamdulillah are all pro Palestinian
pro Gaza alhamdulillah so their loyalty
is clear where it is so let's not make
this a thing of Somali landers the
people of the Somalis yes no I'm so
sorry okay it's the same with uh Turkey
having a deal and many other countries
so let's let's be just here yes and we
those people don't represent they have
gone out on the streets protesting etc
what their government do and what they
themselves I think are two separate
things. Here's a video of a brother who
was watching this and in utter shock.
Yes. Here's uh one clip in. Let's watch.
>> This is literally Somali land right
here. All right. Let's keep it 100. We
all know why Israel recognized Somali
land. It's because it's close to Yemen.
But let's be honest. What does Somali
land even gain from this? Bro, you're
literally getting recognized by the most
hated country in the world. literally
the most hated country in the world. Not
only that, they dead ass killed hundreds
of thousands of other Muslims and
are jumping around dancing.
Like I never seen nothing that's lower
than that. If it was recognition from
any other country, I would have been
like, "Okay, that's fair."
But Israel will giggy. I never talk
about kabadic. I'm going to be so
honest, right? People didn't even know
what my kabil is on the internet. I'mma
be I'm going to keep it a 100 because at
the end of the day we're all Somali.
That doesn't matter. But when it comes
to snaking out your Muslim brothers,
bro, this is damn near the same. Just
for some recognition. Just for some
recognition.
>> Okay, good. Now, we just want to go to a
video of what was happening in Somalia
in the city of Muslim Harisa. Yes. Okay.
And there you go. Now, I'm going to read
a video from a a the news article from
um
Alazer. But before I get to that guys,
guys, as you can see that brother there,
he represents the Somali landers like
the the people the in that in that
specific region and country want their
independence. Understandable. But that
is the voice of our Somali brothers and
Somali landers. Let's make that very
clear inshallah because don't get it
twisted with the government. And I ask
Allah subhanaa tala to destroy I have
any government. I don't care if it's
Turkey. I don't care if it's Kurdistan.
Uh I don't care if it's Somali land,
Somalia, Egypt, UAE. I don't care
wherever it is. Yes. Wah. All I'm going
to say is may Allah subhanaa tala deal
with oppressors. May Allah subh deal
with those who are putting hand holding
hand in hand with those who are
massacring. It's as good as somebody
massacring your family members and you
hold their hand. Why? Because of
tribalism or whatever it is or you have
an issue with Somalia or whatever it is
for that matter for political gains that
you will go and sell your soul to this
level and wall Allah will not wall and
this is a strategic move from Israel.
Israel do not care. Okay. Israel hates
its own Israeli, you know, the black
Israelis. Yeah. Okay. Black Jews that
come there, they have racism, okay? Let
alone you. They don't care about you
guys. And the the Somali people know
this. Somali landers, they know this
very clearly. Subhan Allah. And it's a
strategic move with this move. That's
what they're doing. But for uh um this
the president of Somali land to go down
this route, wall, I ask Allah subhana wa
tala to break your back, bro. I ask
Allahh put no baraka. May it be a
absolute disaster for you and your
government, not the people of Somalia or
Somalander. Yes. Okay. Somaland for you
and subhan Allah. You and your
government. Yes. Okay. On your Makyama,
your hands are going to be in blood that
you parttook in this. Why? At the cost
of what? Yes. What advantage? For what?
Hey, you sold yourself. The prophetam
said the um is one body. If one part
aches with you, yes. You don't even see
yourself as that body. You don't even
see yourself that body. And every single
nation and country that is joining hands
in hand with these genocidal scums, you
are going to be remembered in history.
This what Alazer had to say. Islam is
Israel becomes first country to
recognize Somali land. Okay. Break u
breakaway region of Somalia uh achieved
diplomatic breakthrough after more than
30 years without any international
recognition. Okay. Israel has become the
first nation in the world to formally
recognize Somaliand marking a
significant diplomatic breakthrough for
the break uh for the breakaway region in
the Horn of Africa. Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu, may Allah subhanaa
tala destroy him into pieces, announced
on Friday that Israel and Somali land
has signed a joint declaration
establishing full diplomatic relations
describing describing it as being in the
spirit of Abraham Accords. A set a set
of deals brokered by the United States
to establish form ties formal ties
between Israel and Arab states. Somali's
government released a statement hours
after Israel's announcements calling the
move an attack on its sovereignty
sovereignty and an unlawful action and
describing Somali land as an in
inseparable part of the country.
Somaliand declared independence from
Somalia in 1991 but it but it has failed
to gain recognition from any United
Nations member state. the region
controls of the northwest uh
northwestern portion of what was once
the British uh protect protectorate in
northern Somalia. Somalia has never
accept Somaland's independence. So
Somali's foreign minister Abdul Salam
Abdul Ali participated in the call for
the foreign minister of Egypt, Turkey,
Turkey and Djibouti during which they
reiterated their support for Somali's
unity. The Egyptian foreign minister
said the four countries the four
countries top diplomats discussed how
recognizing the independence of reg of a
region with a sovereign country sets a
dangerous president in violation of the
UN charter. Respect for the unity
respect for the unity sovereignty and
territorial integrity of state is a
fundamental pillar of the stability of
the international system and must must
not be violated or circum circumvented
under any pretext. The ministry said so
Netanyahu Netanyahu the scum
congratulated Somaland president Abdah
Muhammad may Allah break your back
Abdullahi known as Abd Rahman Jiro
whatever that means uh during a video
call praising his leadership and commit
commitment to promoting stability and
peace and inviting him to Israel wall
what utter dirt back you have to be wah
how could you do this to your own people
what an absolute shame in history yes
you you you yes subhan allahra Israel's
foreign minister Gileian Sa um said that
said the agreement followed a year of
extensive diplomatic
dialogue between the two governments and
was based on a joint decision by
Netanyahu and Kiro Chiro to establish
full ties including the appointments of
ambassadors and the opening of uh
embassies in the country. Yes, Allah the
history is going to remember you dirt
bags. Okay. We will together we will
work together to promote the relations
between our countries and nations
regional stability and economic pro
economic prosperity. Sar wrote on social
media adding that he will he has
instructed his ministry to immediately
inst institutionalize ties across a wide
range of fields and chiro the dirt bag
may Allah deal with him welcomed the
development as a historic moment
expressing readiness for Somali land to
join the Abraham Accords. And this is
what happens guys when you don't put
your trust in Allah and think that by
doing this and going to these snakes and
these genocidal maniacs who have
massacred your brother brothers and
sisters today's them tomorrow it's going
to be you. Okay. And that you're going
to go to them and by doing this you're
going to establish your land at the
bloods of the gardens. You are going to
the blood of the gardens. Yes. Okay.
Allah is going to destroy and not only
that on your makyama. Why? Because
tribalism nationalism the disease. This
is one of the biggest diseases and
having in can you imagine look if you
went to your like I understand yes you
want your own independences Muslim
nations do not want to know wall I would
rather not have an independent state
then go to these guys wall it is better
it is better and I don't know what that
means you not having independence okay
we understand it's something that you
want but to go to the snake of the snake
to go to el to go tol get where you want
should You worship your own self, bro?
Is this even for your people? Y, you
would go to a scum of the earth, the
most hated country in the world, and go
and hold hands with them and kiss their
hand. Why? Because you want independency
for your people. Well, I genuinely
believe if the Somali people, the Somali
landers voted, they will all be against
this move. All of them. But the
government is the government and they
are separate from our brothers, Somali
landers and Somalia, Somalis in general.
Uh that's all I want to say inshallah.
Very very disappointing. Very
disheartening. So much for it was an AI.
What can you say? May Allah bless our
Somali brothers and silanders.
Alhamdulillah. Again me even saying this
maybe it's problematic that I'm
differentiating between the two. Uh you
guys the um is one. Yes. And we should
all be together against this. And our
Somali brothers um and again I'm just
saying Somali landers because I don't
they might say okay we are separate
whatever for that matter. Have been in
the Gaza protest. They have been active.
I can remember Somali sisters who were
ripping down posters of Israel things.
So alhamdulillah brother and sisters do
not fall for thinking that our Somali
brothers and sisters are or Somali
landers brothers and sisters and they
are with this I believe they are
strongly against this inshallah may
Allah bless and preserve you
guysamlaykum
may Allah make us those who have tawak
Allah subhanaa tala and not in the means
let alone the means coming from beliefs
goodbye everything you own from your
clothes to your car to your wife or your
husband is going to forget you and move
on and be replaced the moment you die
that's why Allah says
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count, brothers and
sisters, and donate towards this
message, inshallah, a new project that's
only $500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makayyama. And
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.